say it isn't so
but Dancing with the Stars tour will be
missing the moves of reigning champ
Rumer Willis the 26 year old revealed on
Instagram Thursday that she suffered an
injury that will keep her from Dancing
with Pope partner Val Chmerkovskiy on
the road she posted a bleak
black-and-white pic of her injured foot
captioning I have to hang up my dancing
shoes for a little bit because of a few
stress fractures in my foot but fear not
fans rumor also revealed that while she
won't be dancing she will still be
singing live in the show the news comes
just a few days after she was
instagramming how excited she was to
perform on the tour with her fellow cast
members I thought she was gonna do a
couple of shows here and there but she's
actually signing up for majority of the
tour Val told ET earlier this month that
rumor is a huge part of the tour but
there are still plenty of other acts
look forward to the Dancing with the
Stars live perfect-10 event ends its run
on August 11th in Rockford Illinois